[Musique]
depuis des semaines le drame se dérouler
à huis clos mais début avril
l'ampleur de la catastrophe se précise
et l'inquiétude des familles explosent
et à 120 cas à huit décès puis on sait
pas et c'est mon père fait partie des
gens qui ont été testés positifs
michel gagnon était arrivé au ch celle
des de sainte dorothée en février mi
mars
c'est proche n'arrivent plus à joindre
l'octogénaire atteints de la maladie
dans un humain comme en fait ce qu'on va
le retrouver dans quel état il est
est-ce que perdu ce qui nous cherchent
débordé le personnel du ch et celle des
ne répond plus c'est ce que virus de
même on n'a jamais vu son nom au plus
mais
et ont perdu contre oblige les causes de
la catastrophe
ici sont les mêmes que dans les autres
sièges celle des de la région de
montréal qui ont été ravagés par l'aco
vide
y'a pas de fêter ce qui a été fait pour
les masques en 95 on n'avait pas
d'équipement en quantité suffisante dans
les entrepôts on n'avait pas de visière
on a eu de la misère à voter jacques
agent qui ne changent pas de joker entre
les patients se promenait départ j'en
étage de milieu sain un milieu contaminé
des employés potentiellement infectées
qui pouvait transporter l'aco vide vers
d'autres ch et celle des à laval on a
des équipes volantes le sachet solde est
donc une personne qu un poste équivalent
le ch est celle d un temps complet ben
ils pouvaient faire les cinq sachets
celui de laval dans la même semaine en
ayant du personnel qui bougent d'un
endroit à l'autre qui possiblement
peuvent être porteurs et donc vecteur sa
cause d'un problème
consciente des lacunes la famille de
michel gagnon apprend d'abord début
avril qu'il n'est pas atteint je me sens
ok ya passé à travers la première vague
de danser à ses côtés le 2 avril l ail
et négatifs on s'assurer qu'ils restent
négatifs
mais ce n'est pas ce qui va se passer
monsieur gagnon vie dans une section
infecté où il partage la salle de bain
d'une dame atteinte par l'aco vide et
reflux avoir aucun chevauchement au
niveau du circuit du patient qui était
positif donc sa propre salle de bains
son propre cahier son propre couloir
avec des soignants qui sont dédiés à eux
faute de ce genre de mesures la famille
gagnon apprend le 7 avril que leur père
a finalement été contaminées ont engagé
ses partisans et elle est inconcevable
mais à la mi avril le 6 de laval
envoient des renforts aussi à celle d
amélie bouillet fait partie d'une équipe
formée pour rétablir la communication
avec les familles
elle organise des appels effets de court
message vidéo de michel gagnon à son
épouse nicole ce que vous l'aimez bah
oui fm
c'est sûr qu'il savait qui était proche
mais la maladie progresse chez monsieur
gagnon sa fille ginette lui rend une
dernière visite aussi à celle des mais
ensuite le seul lien qui demeure et la
vidéoconférence grâce à amélie besoins
évoluent faire exactement le cas parce
que je faisais part élevé à lui caresser
la joue comme ça tous choisi d'infliger
sa minute il fait exactement ce que je
faisais que d'après quand je jouais on
est là pour pour donner
un petit peu ce que la famille peut pas
donner qui système à grand mère c'est à
mon grand-père leur ait passé la main et
chauffeur puis je rumine main sur la
joue la famille accompagnent michel
gagnon à distante mon domicile je t'aime
beaucoup fait des beaux rêves après un
dernier contact virtuel en matinée
michel gagnon moeurs loin des siens
le 27 avril il est l'un des visages de
cette catastrophe aussi h et celle des
de sainte dorothée où près de la moitié
des quelque 200 résidents sont morts de
la coved 19
le sis de laval n'a pas voulu commenter
ce lourd bilan puisque des recours
juridiques se prépare ici david
gentilles et radio canada montréal